[Music]
[Music]
here we are on the friendship onion and
we're still in a festive christmassy
mood but maybe more of a kind of new
year's evie kind of mood right well i
think we should done because i think it
starts around the 20th of december and
it takes me right through the third of
january yeah that's i i want to be
festive right through all that time yeah
christmas isn't just about christmas day
it's about the christmas holiday season
all your friends and having some time to
recharge and be thankful for all that
you've got isn't that a nice time of
year yes it's a while it's the most
wonderful time of the year i think and
now it's new year
and the start of a whole fresh year what
have you got planned on well i've always
subscribed to you know loving new year's
eve and the whole idea of like it
doesn't necessarily matter the mistakes
that you've made
yesterday or on new year's eve last year
it's a brand new year tomorrow morning
you get a chance to start again so
i don't know really i think just trying
to be a nicer person you couldn't be any
nicer don't it's lovely you've hit
peak nice person yeah i might have for
me i might have topped out pnp what
about you i don't you're not a man for
resolution i'm not i'm not one for
resolutions i don't buy into it tom if i
want to make a resolution i'll make that
whenever i want during the year
but uh i do like i do like the start of
a new year and yeah as you say it feels
good it feels fresh
and i'm excited
i love it you told me years ago it's the
hope that kills you that's what you say
maybe it is maybe it's not well it's
nice to see you at the start of this new
year yes and i'm looking forward to this
another friendship onion and we get to
wear the hats
again hats again we're going to be
answering questions from people we're
probably going to be doing another
episode of billy and dom eat the world i
hope so maybe we'll open some of these
gifts if we have time we just don't know
we haven't even got through them yet
shall we do one just now one which come
on let's have a look i know you love
opening gifts let me do one another come
on we've already opened this yeah that
was a good one
right thanks john oh it's flat it's very
flat
right what do you think use this
nothing nothing in this one
oh really nothing that was a terrible
gift whoever said that
it's from uh
someone in l.a nothing in there nothing
ready for this one job
right from australia thank you to
everybody who sent us gifts it's very
very kind look at this one dom
it's a calendar of australia has it i
don't know looks like it would you say
that's australia probably is that true
probably oh look at that
bill's beach mate here grab a hold of
that i'll tell you what it is you have a
look there's some lovely pictures in
there
right
oh mother may i
i don't know i think these are photos
that the person's taking themselves well
done that's just that dom it's not even
for us isn't it it's for my wife
i can't i better not at all i don't know
it's not for us that's lovely dear ali
it says
thank you for sending stuff to my wife
at the friendship onion the very last
picture is just
rocks isn't that lovely beach rocks
absolutely i love the beach i like the
beach too life's a beach that's what
they say there you go dog thank you
darling thank you i'll get that to ally
whoever sent that thank you for sending
all your your
christmas gifts in and also if you guys
have made a new year's resolution and
you want us to keep you or hold you
accountable for it please let us know
what that news resolution is and then
we'll check in with you
throughout the year or you can check in
with us and let us know how you're doing
with it and don loves
new year's resolutions so he will hold
you accountable i'm a fan of making new
year's resolutions so remember you can
always send us an email at the
friendship online at castmedia.com
or you can send us a voice actual voice
actually your voice at the speak paper
speak dot com forward slash the
friendship onion nailed it absolutely
nailed it right should we um let's move
on john
[Music]
billy it's time for another
amazing
segment of quirky worky where we find a
wonderful
person with a unique or fascinating job
from around the world up to now we've
only had human beings are we sticking
with that dog still a human still a
human and we'll find them well we on our
computer screen yes give us a name dom
give us a name well today we're going to
be talking to the wonderful andy hennin
and andy we're going to give you a
little introductionary blurb here shall
i do this or do you want oh no you do it
john because it's lovely that's sandy
look forward to this andy's a musical
therapist and it says hey andy is a
musical therapist music therapist living
and working in harrisburg pennsylvania
she has been a music therapist for three
years where she utilizes the power of
music to help clients reach their goals
whether those are mental emotional
physical or skill based she currently
works for a company that provides
services to individuals with special
needs such as autism and developmental
disabilities now andy this is a
fascinating job tell us about this it
really is
hello anzie hi andy hello hello hi nice
to meet you guys how does this look so
the um so music therapy is a clinical
and evidence-based use of musical uh
music interventions to accomplish
individualized goals within a
therapeutic relationship by um
like a credentialed professional and a
client so
you can use music you know for for
anyone from birth to death really
okay
so
let's start with how did music come into
your life where was that where were you
first introduced to that
i joined fourth grade band and it kind
of it kind of just went from there i've
been you know in anything musical
anything i could get my hands on my
whole life
and uh it's just a really
big part of who i am as a person and
what did you play in band
i started on the saxophone that was my
first love yeah and then
when i was around 16 i i started taking
drum lessons and that's what i focused
on pretty much for through college and
stuff oh paradiddles and all that
so did you always
did you always think you were going to
do some sort of job associated with
music andy
no i actually went to my first semester
of college i was i went for psych
because i didn't know music therapy was
a thing right um
and because i really liked helping
people and then someone said well why
not music therapy space which majors and
then i decided to do music therapy so
how so how does it work you can play
certain instruments and you also want to
help
people you're going down that psych
route so how do you combine those two
things just talk us through what an
average day kind of looks like for you
yeah
there are four main types of musical
interventions so there's receptives so
maybe we listen to a song together and
then we talk about it um
it can help with relaxation it can help
develop maybe auditory skills
we can recreate a song if there's a song
that you really like maybe you can play
it on guitar and you can sing it and
then it can kind of be a form of
self-expression um
or maybe you can play a drum and we can
work on motor skills
um improvisation which is my favorite
like drum circles could be a form of
communication especially for people who
maybe struggle with like verbalizing
their feelings maybe they can just kind
of express that musically
yeah and then composition so
writing music
this is really popular in older adults
kind of like legacy work like leaving
behind the legacy for their family
members
it really just depends on the client and
what they need
so yeah
so the company you you're working for
just now they would be involved in all
parts of that would p
like
so you're not you're not based in a
center
helping people as a anyone can come to
your company and say we would like
you to come to us is that how that works
so the company i work for yeah is more
specific for developmental disability
autism traumatic brain injuries stuff
like that so a lot of our focus is um
kind of helping them with decision
making
self-expression communication
um and stuff like that so yeah
i know back in glasgow i've got a friend
who who does this work and he's asked me
a few times to go in
and then uh
just be part of the group you know going
with a guitar and and play some music
and everybody's got drums and and it's
fantastic and and talking to the people
that work
in the the center that he goes into
he tells me it's the
most people in that center
and
sometimes it's quite severe um
disabilities will
really look forward to that day more
than anything else they're doing they
just love the music they just love being
part of i suppose being part of a group
again and just kind of you know being
part of creating something
right yeah i think there's a lot of
individuals who are non-verbal but maybe
love music and that really really
connect to it and it's like you're
saying like it's a chance for them to
really connect with others yeah and it's
all excuse me and it's all kind of
individually assessed by you in terms of
if if two
different people came to you with the
same problem you know a death in the
family or something like that you would
have to work out exactly how music
speaks to those individuals and then
kind of gear it around them is that
right
yeah i mean i think i think music is
such a
unique experience for each of us
individually that we really have to
focus on what works for that person so
that we can
just for the best success in the
therapeutic relationship um
what about you personally andy what's
your favorite type of music your
favorite kind of genre or artist that
like stand out for you
i
honestly love every single kind of music
i think there's a time and a place for
everything
some of my favorites probably like amy
winehouse i think her songwriting skills
are incredible
um i really like hozier
yeah
i love everything
what's your main instrument now
pretty much every day i mostly play
guitar and sing
it's really easy to sit in front of
somebody hold the guitar and like really
connect with them yeah um and a lot of
percussive instruments for those so we
can incorporate um the client as well
because i think it's easier for people
to pick up a set of shakers and play
along if they if they don't have musical
skills and with you doing this and just
thinking about you personally now when
you're using music to help people sort
of all day
do you do you still feel like after that
like at night you do you like do you
still play music in the house or do you
play in a band or do you do anything
like that
i really like
i know a lot of people get a little bit
burnt out yeah in their careers when
it's the same thing as their hobby but i
honestly i just i feel really blessed
that i found this career because i'll go
home and i'll just play some of my
favorite songs and
i can really relax or on the drive home
play my favorite music and it helps me
to kind of transition to like from work
to personal life so
fantastic
and and do you is there any like is
there songs that just
always work
like if someone's having a hard time or
whatever that you're like you know the
long and winding road or oh you know
that always calms people down that is
always a is there anything like that is
that a universal
or not really no i
i honestly don't i don't think so i
think it's just that everybody's
different and someone could have a you
know a weird bad reaction to a song that
maybe worked for somebody just you know
just previously right but there's yeah i
think there's this i mean
i think you could as a broad
sweeping generalization
i think if the three of us now just did
a quick verse of the birdie song we'd
feel much better
yeah do you know the birthday song
happy birthday no the birdie song you
started bills you'll know it andy we'll
just do a quick rendition of it and
you'll feel so much better from what we
hear it started off in germany and it's
taken over the world you can use this
whenever you like auntie we'll follow
your line are we ready
[Laughter]
no there's nothing that can make you
happy about that
better that's true i'll add it to my
repertoire for sure
you definitely should it's great yeah um
have you noticed andy any specific
changes or
or
things occurring during this
crazy
covid world that we're all living in now
is there a higher level of
anxiety and need for the for the work
that you do
um previously i worked in an inpatient
psychiatric hospital and i feel like
there you know there is a kind of uh
maybe more stress and more anxiety and
people coming in and kind of
especially people who are typically they
struggle with socialization and now
they're more kind of isolated um
that's definitely where i currently work
um
covet has mostly impacted our ability to
meet in person which has been uh the
biggest struggle probably
because i think
i'd be pretty sure in saying that music
in person
must be much more impactful than than
this ovarism you know to actually
be in a room where a string has been hit
or a drum has been hit is is something
different isn't it
yeah we do what we can and try to keep
people safe but we do have some in
persons with distance and masks and
stuff and
we do our best so lovely
to be able to spend your life like that
um
and there's a quote i like and i've
never been able to find it i've said it
on before
so i'm hoping maybe i made it up in
which case i'm much smarter than i
thought it was is it right if you don't
like uh
cheese with holes in it just cut the
holes and leave them on the side of your
plate no that was one of yours
i'm sure i read somewhere somebody said
that art is how we decorate space and
music is how we decorate time
oh that's great and i thought that was
lovely like how kind of it just
he's my favorite thing to do in the
world andy lie in the bath with my
favorite album on drinking a glass of
wine i can attest to that very often i'm
trying to get a hold of him at night and
uh he won't he won't send me a text back
and then a few hours later he'll say
i was in the bath listening to kenny g
covered in bullets
probably not kenny annie de franco it
used to be back
i've got about five or six bath albums
that uh sort of rotate and sometimes one
or two will get added to it do you uh
have on heavy rotation rubber ducky by
bert and ernie cause they're in the bath
when they're singing that rubber ducky
you're the one
you make bath times lots of fun
i'll certainly be looking that one up
dumb it's a good one it sounds like andy
knew that one yeah it's a good one
of course well andy what a fascinating
job and also what an inspiring thing to
have taken something that's brought you
so much joy growing up and turned it
into something that now pays you wages
and helps people that's so cool andy
yeah thank you yes i love what i do so
nice to meet you andy thank you very
much for coming on that's it's wonderful
yeah thank you nice to meet you guys too
have a lovely festive season andy yes
yes you guys too happy new year
bye-bye happy new year
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counselling
done securely online and there is a
broad range of expertise available which
may not be locally available in many
areas the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor and you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matters so they make it easy and free to
change counsellors if needed visit
betterhelp.com that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional counsellors in all
50 states special offer for the
friendship onion listeners get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
hello hi now this week tom we're doing
something very special i think it's
something that you enjoy but we can go
into that a bit further but dom it is in
fact
apple
cider
vinegar or as it's known in the health
industry
acv
is that what they call it they call it
acv what for
just to be cool and trendy all right
now this is um
a lot of people in the health industry
swear by this am i right though yes
billy i absolutely love it now for the
longest time there
i was drinking
lemon juice in one of those big
you know water bottles that you carry
around but i realized that over a couple
of days or so if you don't finish the
lemon juice the lemon juice will
spoil and then you get kind of strange
tasting lemon juice apple cider vinegar
is obviously preserved and will stay as
it is
at infinitum and it's one of my all-time
favorite drinks i'll pull you a little
shot which we're going to cut with water
bills so we'll put a little bit of apple
cider vinegar in there and while you do
that if you don't mind i'd like to get
into the history of vinegar if you could
the history of vinegar starts around
5000 bc
when the babylonians used the fruit of a
date palm to make vinegar they used it
as a food source and as a preserving or
pickling agent vinegar residues have
been found in ancient egyptian urns
traced back to 3 000 years bc wow it is
so good for you it's almost a little bit
of a panacea vinegar what does that mean
it means that it goes into your body and
it works out itself what it needs to do
where it needs to heal you do you have
an earache i'll heal that you have a
headache i'll hear that do you do you
have a problem with your digestive
system or maybe a sore toe i'll head
there it's a brilliant thing to get into
your system i'm always drinking apple
cider vinegar and especially
this apple cider vinegar brags
because it contains this thing called
the mother which is almost a kind of
living element to the vinegar because
it's unpasteurized so the vinegar
becomes stronger over time
i have i have a bit of a history with
this vinegar that we can go into
it in depth
after we've tried this let's have a
little taste down the hatch
no i won't i probably will will ya love
it
sour
ah
makes you doing that nice with you
oh hit me in the streets push that up
i love it
it's very very good for you if you
haven't this is my own personal
testimony here yeah
if you're having digestive problems
let's say you've eaten a particularly
heavy pizza and it's sitting heavily on
your stomach a shot
or two
of apple cider vinegar will allow it to
move uh through also i'm susceptible to
losing hearing in my right ear what
yes and if i drink a shot or two of
apple cider vinegar
it can sometimes heal that problem too
it's brilliant it's one of my favorite
things to drink i absolutely love it
it's gonna get high scores for me and
with that in mind i'll read you a little
blurb the word vinegar did you read this
comes from the latin word for sour wine
did you read this no and has been used
for thousands of years most people
consume it in salad dressings or sauces
however it has been used for many things
vinegar is one of nature's great gifts a
true natural product any alcoholic
beverage whether it be from apples
grapes dates rice or plain white sugar
once exposed to air will naturally turn
to vinegar
it's the bacteria in the air that
converts the alcohol in cider wine and
beer into acetic acid giving vinegar its
sharp sour taste now tell people about
your particular personal story with
vinegar i didn't mind that too much
there but for a long time i couldn't
take this vinegar done because
as you know
uh quite a few years ago now i had
gallstones
in my gallbladder
and uh
it gave me
incredible pain the probably the worst
pain that you've had in your life
physical yeah not like
i tell you why it's so bad dumb it it
stays for a long time
so i'd know when it was coming i'd get
this sort of like oh heartburn
and i'd be like oh it's beginning
and i'd read a lot about this
this vinegar you know apple cider
vinegar so then i would start drinking
this to try and stop it
becoming worse but it would it would get
worse tom and then it would drop and in
my lower stomach and and just the pain
would never go away stabbing him no like
dull ache and say this was about
nine o'clock at night i'd try stretching
and get myself in different ways and i'd
be drinking this vinegar and it'd just
be awful and it would stay with me
honestly till about six in the morning
jesus and i had no comfort it was awful
painkillers didn't help well do you know
what looking back at it now i hardly
ever took painkillers because in my mind
always think that painkillers are bad
for your stomach right right
and
all the pain was in my stomach good
point so it just subconsciously i didn't
really do painkillers i was doing this
vinegar
and um
and now as i say i'd have it for about
eight or nine hours this pain and a
couple of times it took me to the er
where they would give me heavy
heavy painkillers
and that was good time you were unwell i
was away working on a job and you had
been to new zealand to work on the
hobbit and the next time i saw you oh
you'd lost a lot of weight dom i was
down here 124 pounds that is what about
nine stone something like that maybe
maybe
it's very light for me if you don't mind
me saying you were a shadow of your
former self there was my clothes were
falling off and there was nothing to do
like because i couldn't eat oh no when
it started it used to be uh maybe i i'd
had i'd have to avoid white bread
or or things that were very fatty
but then it got like i couldn't eat any
carbs and then it got that i couldn't
eat anything but fruit
and then i couldn't eat through it
because your gallbladder creates a
calcified stone that usually gets passed
but when it gets so big it can't pass
through the gold duct yeah you got it
done
and it just sits there and yours i've
seen yours because we extracted them
through about the size of a couple of
marathon peas and i was thinking i'm
making you can say yes or no to this
two necklaces i'd have one you'd have
the other
and then we would always have a piece of
me
hanging from your neck have you smelt it
does it smell anything it doesn't smell
of anything yeah i'm going to get a
spray it's been a few years now i
haven't looked at them for a while but i
hope they have it where are they
they're on on my bookcase yes but i hope
they haven't like disintegrated because
otherwise he could have stayed in my
gallbladder
i had to get the thing removed i
remember now what happens when you get
your goal bladder removed what
happens moving forward so here's the
gallbladder dom the gallbladder sits
uh wherever it sits and it takes the um
what'd you call that bile bile
from your liver and it and it keeps it
in this little gallbladder now when you
eat something fatty it squeezes itself
and it's
it squirts some um this bile into your
stomach helps you dissolve the fat so
basically i don't have that little
reservoir now it just goes from my liver
straight and in my stomach i suppose and
it doesn't cause any issues luckily uh
you know fingers crossed and touch wood
i have been all right and i feel i feel
the benefit done no i would not i would
not wish that pain on my worst enemy
well if that was still going on now
after you know all that time ago that
you had it i don't think you'd be with
us anymore yeah you probably would have
talked to yourself well i'd be about six
or seven pounds your poor thing yeah i'm
going to read this during biblical times
vinegar was used to flavor food and as
an energizing drink and medicine is
mentioned in both the old and new
testaments for example
in ruth ruth i didn't know ruth was a
book in the oh yeah ruth the book of
tina the book of sheila in the book of
ruth 2 14 it says after working hard in
the fields ruth was invite invited by
boaz to eat bread and dip it in vinegar
well what a date night that was
fantastic but so i used to use this to
try and stop this gallbladder pain yeah
i think it worked at the start maybe
but then those long nights done
or just me
i would i would drink gallons of this
trying to get rid of this pain
so then i associated this with that pain
so i i haven't had it since you're all
right with it now it's pavlovian isn't
it that's a pavilion response i like
pavlovian responses but now i think i'll
get back on you and i'll do how much
would you take would you say to be
medicinal so i have one of those big
kind of i would say at least half liter
bottles and i put a glog i would say
maybe about that much really
probably three or four tablespoons
in a half liter bowl and i just sip that
throughout the day and it's been
brilliant for things like my digestive
system and
yeah
general you swear by it it's good i love
it i absolutely love it it also has a
strong history in africa and china dom
as an alternative medicine it contains
vitamin c and b as well as acetic acid
acetic acid which increases the body's
absorption of important minerals from
foods we eat and slows down the rate at
which the body turns carbohydrates into
sugar wow fascinating there's so much
blood isn't it that's a lot doesn't it
here's another study out of japan in
2007
said the fact they found that consuming
apple cider vinegar resulted in weight
loss in mice in 2007 a study was done
using a group of type 1 diabetics it
found that giving apple cider vinegar
had slower rates of gastric emptying the
rate at which food moves from the
stomach to the small intestine this can
help people feel fuller for a longer
amount of time which may reduce the
total food consumption intake therefore
aiding in weight loss the study also
tracked cholesterol and
triglyceride levels they were lower
however it may also be due to the
reduction of food intake the results
were slightly unclear ah well there we
are but you you i mean
you know you swear by it very good for
you um
as it says on here good in good in
salads yeah if you're getting an apple
cider vinegar make sure you get one that
is
not pasteurized or
unpasteurized because then the vinegar
inside the vessel can continue to get
stronger because the living culture is
still around around if you heat it
through pasteurization
it's kind of a dead vinegar and you want
it to get stronger and stronger i like
it though i like it's good forever does
say it's good to put into salad
dressings and sausages as you say but i
also said add to your favorite smoothie
i don't know if i'd put it in a smoothie
strawberry and banana and and vinegar
not for me not for me i like it a little
bit more as a kind of wellness shot so
you do a little apple cider vinegar
maybe a little bit of
cayenne pepper a little turmeric top it
up with some water maybe put some beet
pollen in there and take it as a shot
yeah and because it's a bit of a
shocking taste isn't it oh yeah yeah
yeah actually quite hard but apple cider
vinegar is one of the mildest of
vinegars as you know because yeah
because other stuff like white vinegar
yeah spirit vinegar is extremely
powerful yeah you wouldn't want to drink
that but this is not terrible
during biblical times
vinegar was used to flavor foods
as an energizing drink and as a medicine
and it still is done it's been around
for a long time and as we were talking
about just then if you leave any fruit
or vegetable item out in the air yeah
the bacteria will degrade it and very
often turn it into a vinegar-like
substance but you want to be careful
that don't just be drinking the juice of
rotten fruits
no no no hey dom right come on let's
give it some score scores first of all
flavor and or taste i mean it's an
acquired taste do you acquire a taste
for it it does i love it now do you yeah
and also each bottle is different this
one's a much less sweeter one than the
one that i've got at home they're all
different the different
the different brews of it i'm gonna give
it a good i'm gonna give it a classic
nine out of ten a nine out of ten bang
on there just lost one point now dom i
can really only give her a
5.7 okay all right it's not for you
because you you have that pavlovian
response to it uh aesthetics
how would you describe that color what
color is that claudia piss cloudy piss
is a great great example of that color
there i mean is that orange what is that
like a rust color oh it's rusty mild
rust yes rusty um
the bottle is is quite iconic now this
bottle has been yeah i like the ball i
like the 1812 that
over a hundred years wow this company's
been making apple cider vinegar well
side has been around you know five
thousand years before
christ that's true
um
yeah i mean i i like the design of this
bottle it's simple
i've had it in my house for many years
in terms of the aesthetics of the
vinegar itself it might drop a couple of
points i'm gonna give it
a seven
well yeah i like i like when things have
a sort of traditional look you know i
like things to look and this looks kind
of traditionally me so i'm going to give
it a i'm going to give it a 7.5 lovely
zero calories in uh apple cider vinegar
just saw that on this how can that be
yeah what what's uh all right is it like
water that means zero anything there's
no fat there's no calories there's no
carbohydrate there's nothing in it
there's no salt it's not a significant
source of uh saturated fats trans fats
cholesterol dietary fiber total sugar
added sugar vitamin c
iron potassium there's nothing in it
it's simply vinegar simply vinegar
organic apple cider vinegar
and then finally
usefulness my god i mean
it's good for your hair it's good for
your skin it's good for your eyes it's
good for your digestive system it's good
for headaches it's good for ear eggs i
can attest to that has this been proven
i don't think so hasn't it well i don't
think so
certainly not by me but it makes me feel
better if i eat something that i know is
going to be heavy yeah i'll either start
with a shot or two of apple cider
vinegar but certainly end the evening
with a few glugs of apple cider vinegar
i make it my business when i go to sleep
at night i take all my clothes off and i
stand in front of my bed and i think
you're gonna get an absolute hammer in
tonight and i take a big massive gulp of
apple cider vinegar
straight straight yeah good
yeah
um well there's a lot of stuff about
studies here one showed an improvement
in insulin
action and the skeletal muscle of human
adults with diabetes and a 2015 study
showed that vinegar consumption and type
2 diabetics improve blood sugar control
insulin and triglyceride levels so it
actually has
been shown to um help in many ways yeah
there's a whole bunch of stuff claims
here you know fat burning weight loss
detox diet
lowering cholesterol
like i said it's been fantastic for me
if i get a headache or an earache
instead of you know taking a painkiller
i'm like well i'll start
with a shot of apple cider vinegar i'll
give it half an hour and very often it
goes well it cleans your system out
cleans it out well that's good yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna give it a 10 out of 10
for usefulness wow yeah it's a perfect
score well i can give it a 10 out of 10
because the bottle does vapor in your
favorite smoothie and i wouldn't like
that flavor in the smoothie unless it
was just purely
i didn't even taste it there and i just
saw your face and it made me feel a bit
sick yeah i'm sorry and so i can't give
it a huge score dom but uh after
speaking to you and seeing these studies
here um i will have to give her uh
you all right 7.8
lovely
lovely bit of stuff well that was billy
and dom eat the world of course if you
have any suggestions for us as to what
you want us to eat or drink
especially from places that we've never
heard of before or food or beverage
items that we never heard about memories
we're very curious maybe you went to a
town that you've never been to and you
tried this thing if you hunted it down
and you want to suggest it to us we
would love to try it send all your
suggestions to us
at the friendship onion cast media.com
or you could send us a voicemail at
speakpipe forward slash the friendship
speakpike.com forward slash the
friendship on your my bad uh don't worry
about that dom
thanks
that was a fantastic billion draw meet
the world
vinegar
well
that was the
most vinegary of episodes that we've
done so far that's the sourest uh
episode that i think we've done in terms
of flavor it twisted my face in many
different ways that my face has never
done before trusted your melon have you
ever got a dog to
lick a lemon
that's what i felt like does it feel
like a dog licking a lemon but you'll
feel the benefit of that apple cider
vinegar maybe later on when you're
driving home you think oh my uh upper
and lower intestines feel
very very cleaned out does it do into
the pancreas
i'm not sure what it does to the
pancreas but
could you keep me posted on your um
deficatory habits i know i sometimes do
ask you i feel as if it might have put a
road right through me to be honest
i feel like yeah
yeah you don't should we pause the show
no let's carry on we'll see if we can
get to the end that was uh a lovely
festive uh new year's episode billy and
i wish you a
lot of luck and good fortune throughout
2022. of course we will be here with you
guys to um enjoy it with you but just
stay safe over new year's eve enjoy your
time
and uh have a glass of eggnog on us
i hope
i hope you guys have a fantastic new
year and i hope 2022 is your favorite
year yet
what a lovely sentiment
lots of love from the friendship onion
see you next year
[Music]
oh
no
what we're doing now johnny
you're bringing it up
oh have you got it there
no it's not that's the bottom of the
bottom of the page
i was 21
years old
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i don't want to change the world i'm not
looking for new england
i'm
[Applause]
[Music]
you're shining bright i'm your oyster
baby you're my pearl
[Music]